Brian Scalabrine covers the Celtics Ren
BC sports Boston Yahoo Sports SiriusXM
NBA radio back on the program
Brian how are you today yeah I thought
you were gonna ban me after I thought
that Toronto actually had a chance
against the Cavs but glad to be back
thanks for having me well let's clear
that up because you gave a cryptic
message right at the very end of the
last time I talked to you hey let's talk
you know after the Toronto series with
Cleveland as if you thought LeBron was
going to lose yeah I actually did and I
thought what we're seeing right now and
I know he had like the forty two point
triple-double but it doesn't feel the
same way as some of the dominating
performance in the past have been but I
thought that Toronto would not be afraid
and they would be able to challenge
Cleveland and and and sort of the same
MO as Indiana but let's just scrap that
those guys were not ready for that
for whatever reason mentally physically
not having the bodies but let's switch
it over to the Celtics who clearly seem
to be ready to dethrone the king all
right what happens in Game three you
know i'm expecting cleveland to win both
games but I've got the Celtics team
wrong a lot like from the beginning of
the year like that everything is by
blowing my mind you have rookies coming
in and having impacts throughout the
season you know developing getting
better as a year goes along where
typically like a rookie hits the wall
and sort of falls off I just hit him
improved Jalen Brown improved so with
these guys the one thing that everyone
has to understand him we value offense
if we will value LeBron's 42-point
triple-double we'll talk about it and
historic fashion but we don't
necessarily value guys who defend their
position and limit rotation on the
defensive end limit the fact that you
have you don't have to be scrambling and
you can guard guys one-on-one and that's
what the cells have and I don't think
that that's going away it didn't go away
in the Milwaukee series it was
definitely there for the Philly series
and now so far these first two games
these guys have sat down and guards
their yard better than most and you know
up we're up there with the likes of the
Warriors who also do a really good job
of
guys one on one who's the most valuable
Celtic player that's a great question if
I had to pick one of the al horford just
because so many things run through him
and he has versatility you know like the
idea like I like bein he's like what no
he was rated number one in the defensive
rating in the NBA but you can't just
switch everything you can't switch veins
until abroad without he can rebound his
position he can guard a junior Smith off
of down screaming and guard Oh LeBron
off the dribble so defensively out work
for does all the things that you would
want from a center now he's not like
exceptional at any of them but just the
idea that you can do all that makes them
exceptional and then offensively when
the ball runs through him the Celtics
team to move the ball a lot better
side-to-side so right now with Kyrie out
I would have to say Al Horford you have
a head coach and Brad Stevens who didn't
receive any votes for Coach of the Year
but it feels like the media wants to
give him credit for getting his team
this far and then I've seen some recent
comments including one by the former
Celtic Robert Parish like hey we're
giving him way too much credit here he
hadn't won anything so where do we stand
with Brad Stevens roll with Boston
success well I mean he's a great coach
and he puts guys in a great position but
I feel like the little demeaning when
people like people don't give credit to
the players like as good as other
coaches Brad Stevens is like when you
had guys that defend the way that these
guys defend and maybe give a lot of
credit to Brad and his coaching staff
for teaching these guys like how to
defend and how not to over react to
certain things and he all he has to do
is focus on you know putting guys in a
position to be successful without with
without compromising their weaknesses
and he does a really good job with that
but I think it's a little disrespectful
to the players when they win they all
the credit goes to Brad the credit
should go to the players who do the work
day in and day out
well how about Danny Ainge who brought
all these players in does he deserve
more credit than Brad Stevens does no I
mean I don't I think in the Celtic
organization
you can look from ownership down
ownership has to sign off on an Isaiah
trade for Kyrie Irving they have to know
that Kyrie Irving is going to be a 37
and 38 million dollar a year player
somewhere down the road and then you're
giving up a pick Danny Ainge has to
convince them no this is the way to go
Kyrie is a special player we needed
Danny Ainge has to sign off the
ownership has to sign off on trading
away you know you're too Hall of Fame
players you just brought a championship
for you know the all these Brooklyn
picks that are coming your way so and
then yeah then you got to pick the right
guys along the way in and get
scrutinized for not making a Jimmy
Butler trade when you have to trade
deadline in by the national media that
Danny Ainge is making the wrong moves
but I'm not making moves and so everyone
has to be on the same page and whether
the move is right or wrong ownerships
gonna back Ainge Ames in the back
Stephen to see that Stephenson is gonna
back both those guys so it's hard to win
in the NBA especially if you don't have
like the Kevin Durant and LeBron Zoar go
down to was quite Leonard whoever but if
you you definitely got to be on the same
page and I think right now the Celtics
more than most organizations seem to be
all locked in together with the same
goals in mind Brian Scalabrine NBC
Sports Boston joining us Dan Patrick
show if Boston had Kyrie and Gordon
Hayward finish their sentence then they
would have a really good chance of
beating the Warriors I just don't know
offensively if they have enough ever we
saw that no it was ridiculous watching
them play Houston where James Harden
actually was doing his thing and Houston
was playing pretty well I get it
everyone can always play better but like
the the idea that the Warriors I had had
these all these guys they have Kevin
Durant out there like at the end of the
shot clock making shots I think this
year I I think everyone has to believe
it they're unbeatable but with Kyrie and
Gordon Hayward I think it was like gives
Boston a chance to beat them but I will
say this like with those guys going down
like it allowed a lot of guys seem to
grow and maybe that's the path to
winning a championship next year maybe
it's
like a silver lining to these guys
development and if these guys can go to
the finals and get that experience it
doesn't seem very likely that they can
go next next year and the Warriors stay
the same and go next year and and
actually compete and people give the
Celtics an actual chance to beat the
Warriors Brian good to talk to you have
fun in the series and if you're Celtics
get to the finals we'll check in with
you again you got it that's Brian
Scalabrine he's the white mama
NBC Sports Boston for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]